is walker that successful i mean it's
got to be successful if they're doing a
prequel to it
i think it's there's so much to it i
mean it is you know it's that there's a
familiar audience and it's it's that
nostalgia that westerns bring out in
people i think you know there's such a
familiarity to it but it with the sort
of resurgence of westerns right now it
provides such a great opportunity to
take a genre that everyone thinks they
know and make it new and make it fresh
and i think you know the the new
walker's been able to do that in a
really cool way with what jared's done
with his show and now taking it back to
the 1870s we're able to do that all over
again um and sort of be
in the universe that very much our own
our own entity did you
were you watching
a lot of walker did you have to watch a
lot of walkers to sort of get ready for
this i mean did you even audition for
this prequel so guys if you're listening
she's obviously doing this prequel to
the show walker that jared padalecki is
on and she's doing the prequel which
takes place in the 1800s now i'm
thinking this is the season season three
of walker
i think so yeah so it's that successful
where all of a sudden they're like let's
do a prequel i mean smaller was super
successful why didn't they do a prequel
i guess we were the prequel because it
was
before they became superman but that's
that shows a lot of uh
a lot of love for the show
oh absolutely and what's what's what i
get a kick out of is you know as far as
cw goes the last time i spoke to you i
was playing stephen amell's daughter 20
years in the future and now in some
other alternate universe i'm playing
jared padilecki's
great-great-great-great-grandmother
and
i just i think it's wonderful there's
some multiverse where you know that
exists and if someone can explain to me
that
history i'll take it